[Musique]
salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo alors on va
regarder aujourd'hui la plus belle
partie du title tuesday prix de beauté
on en reparlera à la fin de la vidéo
vous donnerez votre avis en commentaire
donc nouveau format express la partie a
opposé à ravine chi tam barran j'espère
que j'ai bien lu son nom c'est un grand
maître indien de 20 ans qui est 26 40 et
quelques encore un grand match qu'on
connaît pas et qu'il ya un niveau de ouf
et avec les noirs alireza fille rouge a
donc lui vous connaissez et on va tout
de suite se lancer dans la partie alors
cavaliers f3 cavaliers f6 e3g 6 des 4
alors il a joué avec un ordre de coups
un peu bizarre mais en gros c'est ce qu
axel smith appel le 3 poison s'est joué
des quatre trois cavaliers f3 contrat à
peu près tout ce qui bouge donc là il
joue contre infi enquête au et donc
contre des systèmes soient grünfeld soit
soi est un gain est donc l' avantage du
pion aux trois dans ce type de variantes
ce qui consolide le pion à des 4 et donc
ça empêche que le fou de rire sur la
grande diagonale aller blanche les fous
eux de rock rock décision il aurait
aussi pu mettre son plan dé 5,1 me joue
des six en mode est indienne
ces quatre cavaliers b17 et cavaliers
ces trois géants modeste indienne parce
que vraiment réellement si le puits ont
été en tout cas on serait juste dans une
position type est indienne mais là le
pion en deux trois et ça change beaucoup
de choses puisque évidemment le pion des
quatre est beaucoup mieux défendu les
noirs qui jouent peu 5 les non blancs
qui jouent des quatre tours 8 à 4 donc
clairement on voit que les blancs
attaque allèles dames et les noirs du
coup on attaque est allé droit le 4 et
cavaliers d2 et donc ça ça pourrait
ressembler à des attaques et indiennes à
couleurs inversées
beaucoup de parties de bobby fischer
notamment qui a bien attaqué avec ce
système les noirs ont joué ici cavaliers
fuites donc il va faire le plan
classique arrache cinq cavaliers 7 kg 5
kg 4,06 des dames h4 tout envoyer et les
blancs vont envoyer de l'autre côté
alors si on joue avec ses 5 les noirs
veulent jouer avec des 5 et du cou
ils seront une bonne structure de type
française d'avant sa couleur inversée
encore mais genre super structure ici
puisque le pion à dépasser le centre
donc c'est sympa de jouer donc il envoie
b5 les noirs voire h5 les blancs ont
joué tout ça permettra éventuellement
avoir fait fin au cavalier a fait en
plus tard cavale et 8h sept fous à 3 à
fouet 5 a5 et a6 et là ça va être assez
intéressant pour fil rouge à ce qui va
se passer alors l'idée des blancs se
serait on va mettre avant à 6 l'idée des
blancs ce serait de réussir à affaiblir
ce pion des six à ouvrir des lignes
genre syfy routage ou bon bien cool en
date savent pas grand-chose fois çi ce
même si ça rajoute un peu de pression
mais genre b6 est un rêve ce serait à
bab céder parce qu' il n'aurait sûrement
pas fait c'est pour illustrer maîtres
lecavalier en bessin qu'ils aient
commencé à taper sur ce pion des six
avec les lignes qui s'ouvre à l'ale dame
et la lata kallel d'amd blanc peut être
très rapide et je vais plutôt mettre la
dame en b3 que lecavalier puisque la
dame elle peut venir en b3 puis en b 4
est donc là ça peut aller très vite
côté blanc pour attaquer allèles dame
est donc revenir prendre des six après
éventuellement rejaillir allèles roi en
cas de besoin c'est en gros c'est le
rêve des blancs donc les noirs font à 6
et l'idée sur b prend c'est qu'il veut
faire tout reprend s'en prendre aux
pions et du coup va falloir bouger le
fou est peut-être la tourbe
comme il ya quand même un vis-à-vis
repart en a 8 et c'était une option et
house est d'ailleurs pour protéger le
pion voici une autre option mais
peut-être csa s'expose avec fb 5 mais en
gros
bon allez blanc leurs colonnes ouvertes
et les noirs vont envoyer de l'autre
côté c'est chaud et on oublie de surtout
c'est hyper sympa à jouer pour les noirs
dans tous les cas parce qu'on attaque le
roi et dans la partie en mars que ce que
va faire ravine de ça va être ça va lui
retomber dessus puisque sur à 6 ipv6
pour du coup s'en prendre à ceux qui ont
des 6 et les noirs font c6 est là mais
un truc très intéressant c'est que si tu
fais des cinq n'importe quand bon là il
ya un problème sur le clouage mais au
pire je te presser 5 et je garde le jeu
fermé et si tu fais c'est 5
je fais des 5 et je garde le jeu fermé
et donc il a beaucoup poussé avec les
blancs et prix des espaces à l'el dame
mais finalement il peut pas ouvrir les
lignes et le jeu va du coup se passait
devant son roi alors il a fait dame b3
peut-être il veut faire dame b 4 pour
attaquer mais y aura toujours du foie
fuite pour défendre donc les noirs ont
joué fouet fuite justement tour c'est un
bon ils essayent d'envoyer du jeu mais
de façon tu peux pas ouvrir cavaliers g4
et maintenant on veut amener la dame en
h4 est attaqué le roi alors si on
supprime ce cavalier je vous montre ça
parce que ça va être instructif pour
vous on va prendre 2 h
admettons fougueux v4 je sais pas on
veut faire damas trois ans veut attaquer
les noirs jouent d'armes h théâtre damas
trois disons qu'on a un peu têtu et
qu'on veut jouer pour fou prend des six
cavaliers g5 comprend des 600 voyez vous
même pas de coups de défense avec les
noirs je ne prépare pas je manque juste
la tacc que je vais envoyer elf ou qui
arrivent en d6 qui peut revenir en
défense et la cavalière 3 alsace est
hyper thématique tu veux prépare avec le
pion au 4g cat et on va le cahier en f3
bon il doit prendre ainsi nourri par le
cavalier donc tu comprends et maintenant
on le prend et on menace damas trois
dames âgées de maths donc pour le parent
et on va dire que le roi par en f1
maintenant fou des trois échecs le roi
viandes vins et digne tout reprend 1,3
roi des huns dame prend f2 et on va pas
aller plus loin les noirs ont déjà
récupéré plus ou moins le matériel mais
surtout ils menacent maths en un qui est
imparable donc sur cavaliers g4 on peut
pas s'emparer du cavalier donc il fait
h3 pour le chasser et maintenant d'un
match 4 on le laisse en prise et on
menace d'un point f2 qui provoque h
pranger il répond par âge plongée dont
qui donne ce cavalier gratuitement entre
guillemets au prix d'une pièce
mais il veut aller au prix d'un pion
pardon dans une pièce au prix d'un pion
mais il veut faire cavalier seul des
cinq cavaliers avec trois échecs donner
une deuxième pièce et installe un pion
en f3 et à les mater la main donc les
bleus ont fait cavaliers f1 qui est
assez bien joué cavalier g5 cavale et g3
alors ça permet d'éviter les plans de
type fouet c'est 3g cet ouvrage suite
d'un machin matt puisque maintenant on
contrôle la case achat et on aura le
temps de plus facilement partir donc
très bien de replacer le cavalier non
seulement il vient défendre le roi mais
en plus ils donnent à la casse de sortie
des deux est ici alors ouais les noirs
auraient pu essayer d'attaquer par fouet
cette prendre leur temps fauvez deux
morts truc c'est que pour suroît g7
comme ça peut-être des dessins qui est
découverte donc on va dire fou et 6 pour
blinder cavaliers à deux rois g73 f1
tour à 8 3 1
damages deux fois f1 je voulais montrer
cette position illustrative et là on est
en fait passer le cavalier devant et en
remettant le fond f1 il a réussi à
blinder et envoya toutes les pièces
noires qui sont mobilisés sur cet
endroit mais on n'arrive pas à passer le
fou j'ai de blindes le pion le cas
valait bien d'achat et on n'arrive pas
vraiment à faire de progrès jordan j'ai
un tour h1 tu peux pas ya le cavalier
qui berne donc il faut leur enlever le
cavaliere met un fonds h4 c'est long ça
joue encore un parce que bon c'est
jamais évident de passer avec les blancs
et de défendre surtout en blitz
mais on voit l'idée du joueur indien
pour blinder
alors du coup on va en revenir à la
partie
c'est pas ici alors on était cavalier 20
kg 5
et donc il a fait pas fou et 7,3 g 7
tours à je suis tranquille il envoie
cavaliers avec trois échecs quand même
et ici à vrai dire les blancs vont faire
une grosse gaffe qui va jouer roi f1
mais il aurait fallu plutôt joué gff
fouet fin donc pour couvrir les les
cases parce que suroît f1 pour partir il
y avait un problème et c'est assez joli
a donc là actuellement les blancs ont
deux pièces d' avance dans cette
variante est sûre pions prend serais
content de repartir avec le roi est
gardé une pièce de plus mais là il ya
tout reprendre 3 qui est très
au lit il ya deux pièces on donne encore
une tour puis on prend 1,3 et dames
pranger 3 donc on a une tour une pièce
de moi mais on menace on menace on
menace f2 dame g1 ou menaces d'alger 2
cl cavaliers bouger d'un prof de maths
on menace beaucoup de choses et genre
sur dame b2 pour défendre un peu
latéralement va faire f 2 comme je
disais aux menaces maths en à angers 1
on enlève le fou pour donner du de la
respiration au roi fou détroit et chaque
cavalier e 2 pour essayer de courir j'ai
un
mais en fait tu couvres rien parce que
tu es cloud et aidons camatte donc ça
c'est pour illustrer après gff que si on
part avec l'euro en perd hélas à vrai
dire il fallait faire flouer fin pour
bien contrôler la diagonale et après
tout reprendre trois tours 1 est ok
peut-être on défend mais ça en étant
précis et là surtout pas puis on prend 3
parce qu'il y aurait un math de l'autre
côté avec une nouvelle fois f2 et dames
g1 qui arrivent d'un match trois
suivants ovale fou et sur foucher de
yahvé d'un match 4 maths mais donc il
faut pas reprendre la tour et la partie
continue et c'est compliqué mais c'est
juste pour montrer qu' il faut faire
avec les noirs ils envoient tout il veut
vraiment mater le roi tant qu'il est
dans le coin et pas laisser les pièces
blanches revenir en défense pendant la
partie sur quatre élèves trois échecs
il a fait n'ont pas pu on prend et fouet
fin mai qu'ils étaient très dures à
trouver et malgré tous les sacrifices en
e3 il ya tout qui suit donc c'est hyper
chaud mais il a fait froid et faim donc
là bon il a pris 21 une seconde pour
jouer ce coup là j'imagine que tout le
monde a vu ce qu'il fallait jouer avec
les noirs méfie round jackie francs 7
secondes qui jouent pas qui a et des
deux échecs donc qui gagne la dame
injustifiée la partie fait damage de
d'accord donc plus on prend un f3 à
point lepreau f3 et maintenant roi alors
donc ils essayent de partir ce qui est
assez bien pensé tout de même et rendre
le fou alors il a joué d'alger a
maintenant alors les blancs ont pas fait
roi des deux mais il a fait cavalier f1
bon pourquoi pas cavalier f1 est
maintenant à bord des deux était une
meilleure défense et maintenant les
noirs vont re commettre une erreur
là il fallait jouer
3 ans 1er attaque le pion à f2 est sûre
j'ai prend un f3 jouer tout reprendre 3
et il ya tout qui tombe la maison avec
eux deux qui tombe au prochain gala tour
à 8 qui revient le roi a plus de à plus
de slip je repars wade de tatus fouache
6 et le roi s'en sort pas y'a tout
reprendre et au prochain face et c'est
une cata total il va y avoir match très
rapidement mais en fait il fait pas
le g3 en premier tour prend 2,3 il fait
tout reprendre 3 en premier puis on
prend 1,3 et j'ai trois ans 2e en se
disant bon bah je vais faire g2 ou f2 ou
dame f2 ça va mater et maintenant ça
marche plus du tout les blancs et jour
roi des deux dons qui se barre et il
protège sa première rangée
à noter qu'à l'heure actuelle il a une
tour et deux pièces de plus donc c'est
quand même un énorme avantage matériel
les noirs jugé 2 donc ils envoient il
veut peut-être juste dame f2 et j'ai un
arbre pour récupérer une nouvelle dame
les noirs joue cavalier ce g3 d'aller
blanche qualifié 3par dont ils attaquent
la dame les normes d'un match deux
attaques lecavalier cavaliers pour un f5
pions point f 5 tours j'ai un don qu'il
arrive avec les noirs affaires rêve de
avoir les deux pions pas scellier qui
semble faire une dame mais tour plongé
de d'arranger 2 et d'amd 1
il couvre tout et il se retrouve avec
deux pièces net de plus avec les blancs
et l'attaquent noire existe encore un
peu hein parce qu'il va faire flasher
six tours 8
mais elle se réduit et le noir firoud
déjà très dangereux et très affûté
tactiquement qui va quand même envoyé
malgré que ça sent complètement gagnant
pour les blancs il fait tout ruitz ok il
attaque un peu le pion aux trois dames h
un super coup ça vient petit à touiller
le roi et sa chasse la dame les noirs
jouent et dames
j'ai trois dames f3 donc je continue à
faire le chantage à l'échangé réactif
ces pièces d'un match 4 tours f1 donc là
peut-être tout rachat a été plus fort
mais il fait tour f1 qui paraît logique
il s'en prend pions f2 et fourrages 6 du
coup ils menacent tout prix f3 et le
nasdaq prend des quatre ont déjà on peut
pas tout défendre qu'à valider un
puisque vous prend 2,3 ou 33 ans veut
pas le laisser
bîmes dame prend des cats à tourner un
petit peu roy ces deux fous prend 1,3
bon il a récupéré des pions mais il ya
toujours ces deux pièces de plus et au
final le roi noir peut être plus faible
que le roi blanc qui fait faux b2 il
attaque la dam dam des deux échecs crois
bien
ils se cachent food et 4 maintenant pour
essayer d'augmenter la pression sur le
feu de haie sur le four b2 et là encore
les blancs vont rater le coche
il va rater à bord déjà fou prend des
cas tout de suite et ça va pour
les blancs mais il va surtout raté
d'alger trois échecs tu peux pas partir
en achètent tu te fais maths et et si tu
pars en fuite si adam décison va prendre
des quatre et ça va terminer la partie
mais sur food et 4 il a joué d'alger 2
et padam g3 et maints endroits et fuite
il n'a pas le dame prend des 6 et après
il prend des quatre tours preuve de ça
devient très chaud pour ses miches parce
qu'il ya la dame et la tour sur la
deuxième rangée qui menacent de faire
des maths et il ya aussi la tour en vain
qui peut venir
donc il a joué dame g7 va passer en
accéléré maintenant parce que ça doit
être un gros trail note
ça va mettre des échecs de partout les
deux joueurs vont se rendre coup pour
coup
ça va prendre vie prend b2 il va
récupérer f1 il ya les pions côté noir
et le duo dame cavaliers côté blanc est
un pion en b6 qui est très avancé dans
le camp adverse mais les noirs en tous
les pions voilà c'est vraiment la foire
d'empoigné
on se dit que les noirs ont peut-être
une position plus facile à négocier
parce qu'avec les pions ça va mais à
cette dame ans qui vient ambiguïté ce
cavalier ce roi là quand le cavalier et
le roi se placer comme ça proches l'un
de l'autre c'est difficile pour la dame
de mettre beaucoup d'échecs
donc il va réussir à jouer un petit peu
sur le cloître avec les blancs du à
réussir à revenir vers eux trois pour
pour tout couvrir
il va récupérer avec les noirs le pion
bessette ça continue à mettre des échecs
ça doit probablement être nul avec un
jeu parfait j'imagine ya trop de
potentiel de perpète mais la position
est très chaude
les deux joueurs ne veulent pas faire
nul parce que dans cette taille tels
tuesday on sait qu'il faut mettre des
points et donc c'est toujours dommage de
laisser un demi point passé surtout là
pour fuir ou de ja qui a réussi quelques
pas à éloigner le roi faire un clouage
essaye de monter son bras pour monter
ses pions mais ça enchaîne ça enchaîne
il se cache le roi qui revient à angers
5 le pion qui par an à 4 lecavalier qui
vient donner des échecs aussi qui
récupère encore un pion donc là on dit
que ça tourne plutôt en faveur du joueur
indien maintenant même si on voit pas
trop de risque non plus pour fil rouge à
nîmes et des échecs ils essayent de
revenir en 5 proposait change des dames
les blancs qui veulent pas
deux nuls et qui refuse tout échange et
au final il va tomber alors il va tomber
ici si je refuse toute nue les va tomber
c'est parce que dans cette position là
après roy c4 il est juste tombé alors
pour faire nul il ya un moyen
pédagogique est simple dans les finales
cavaliers confions là c'est que de
savoir que contre un pion à si
lecavalier contrôler la case à deux ce
sera toujours un nul alors la raison
c'est qu'après dix on a trois mètres la
position comme ça et je sais paroisse f4
roi b2 chasse le cavalier mais le
cavalier peut venir en d3 sur roy ces
deux pour le chasser car l épée quatre
rois b3 on semble avoir complètement
chasser le cavalier du contrôle 2 à 2 et
de pouvoir pousser le pion à 2 au
prochain coup hein parce que le car il
doit bouger et contrôlera plus à 2 mégas
cavaliers detroit qui permet d'avoir la
fourchette et du coup ça veut dire que
en réalité dès qu'on a une position où
le cavalier contrôler cette case à 2 il
pourra toujours tourné pour pour m au
pire une fourchette et arrêter le pion
en donnant le cavalier donc ça bien sûr
le joueur le savait mais avant pris dans
la panique le cavalier le machin et où
il a fini par tomber et donc victoire de
fuir ou dja alors après prix de beauté
du tournoi ah ouais ya quand même eu
beaucoup d'erreurs
à mon avis mais après avoir chacun
chacun chacun ses goûts n'hésitez pas en
commentaire dire ce que vous en avez
pensé et remercie ciao ciao
[Musique]